Alan Brinkley why did you call your
history book the unfinished nation well
there's several reasons I think that
have to do both with the character of
the United States and the character of
historical writing America is a nation
of almost unparalleled diversity I think
and as we certainly are aware today with
our present battles on multiculturalism
the task of melding a single nation out
of all the component parts of the
American people is a very difficult one
and I would argue an unfinished one
America is also a nation that is
constantly changing regardless of
diversity it's growing it's expanding
it's transforming itself constantly and
so it's an ever unfinished Society in
that sense as well and then the the
title was also a reference to the way
historians view the past and the way in
which historians are constantly
redefining their own view of the past
the past of course doesn't change but
the way we look at the past changes and
so the writing of history is also an
unfinished process and the title was
meant to refer to all of those things do
you have a favorite character in history
well I'm not sure I do I mean I have
people I admire greatly in history and I
have liked most historians unlike most
Americans I admire Lincoln I admire
Jefferson I admire maybe this is not so
quite so universal I admire Franklin
Roosevelt and many people who are less
prominent in history I can't say that I
have any single favorite historical
figure do you have a period of history
American history that you would like to
mess around with the most well my own
period the period in which I do my own
research and writing is primarily the
1930s the 1940s and I've written a book
about political dissenters in the 1930s
I'm just finishing a book now about the
New Deal liberalism in the late 30s and
World War two so those sort of middle
third of the 20th century is the period
that I've focused my own research on
primarily do you teach I teach at
Columbia
I teach 20th century American
- what year students - all levels from
freshman to graduate students it's it's
a real challenge to find a way of
teaching history that that reaches so
many different levels of students how do
you do it well I try to make history as
accessible as possible by linking it to
particularly for undergraduates by
linking it to a series of stories that
they can understand and by combining the
storytelling quality of history with
some effort and interpretation and
analysis I think also it's important in
teaching to be very organized in your
thinking and the way you convey ideas
much of what you do in teaching it at
the university level is lecturing which
may be an unhappy quality of university
system but but that's the way it is and
students need to be able to take notes
they need to be able to organize what
you say in their own minds and so I
think think being precise and organized
is very important and teaching as well
particularly in the lecture format her
story about you and I know I'm going to
step on a line or two so I'll just try
to try to get it out and see what your
reaction to it is this is from one of
your former students and I was talking
to folks one day and asked him if they
could you know what they remembered from
their days in school on this particular
individual said he remembered when you
were teaching in Harvard and I don't
know the circumstances that you were not
going to stay at Harvard or whatever and
you had a limit to your the number of
students who were a lot in the classroom
and the moment that he'll remember was
the day that say that there were 600
kids allowed in this class that you said
he didn't care how many kids came to
took your course and that's something
like 1200 where they're waiting for you
when you arrived is that a true story
well something like that
I had been teaching a course on America
since World War two at Harvard for for
some years of course I now teach at
Columbia and I had always placed a limit
of 500 students on it
we 500 students and the demand was was
much higher than that but the capacity
of the room was not my last year at
Harvard the I was placed not in the
lecture hall that I had normally been in
but in Sanders theater which is the the
large essentially at the concert hall
the Harvard concert hall which seats
over a thousand people and so I didn't
see any point in turning people away and
then so I that's absolutely right for
the first time I said that that anyone
who wanted to take the course could take
it and in fact exactly 1000 people
signed up for it at the end
did you really showed up the class ah a
bit I mean I had been surprised and very
surprised when I first began teaching
the course of the size of the crowds by
the time this happened I'd been having
these big crowds for some years and so I
was somewhat less surprised but I've
always been a little puzzled by why the
course attracted it's such fast compass
of people did you ever ask the students
why since many came well it's hard you
know it's hard to ask five hundred or
thousand people and get an answer that
would apply to more than a few of them I
think it was in large part that students
are very curious about the recent past
and III know people at Harvard sometimes
tried to make it sound as though it was
simply me and my popularity that drew
all these students but I don't think
that's really the case I I think people
were are very curious about the recent
past they tend not to know as much about
it as they feel they should partly
because in high school courses teachers
tend to run out of time sometime around
World War two or even earlier and also
because these are events that that are
constantly referred to in public
discourse today and when people here
talk about the Vietnam War the civil
rights movement over the Korean War the
Great Society Malcolm X they want to
know something about it and and there's
not they're not very many easy methods
of learning that in our culture and your
history book that we're looking at here
you have periodically what you call
American Voices
and they're just one usually one
I'm gonna hold one up because you just
mentioned one of them and this
particular one here is some copy that
was originally written or spoken by
Malcolm X explain this technique in the
book and why did you use this well I
wanted to convey something of what made
Malcolm X seem first of all so menacing
to so many white people and even some
black people when he was alive and also
why he seems now so prophetic in that
the the rage he expressed the anger he
expressed the critique of American
society he expressed is now a much more
mainstream position certainly among
African Americans and even among many
many liberal and left-wing white
Americans so I think that that's what I
tried to do in almost all of these
pieces of testimony from figures in
American history that run through this
book is try to convey something both of
what made them seem important in their
own time if in fact they were important
than many of the people quoted here were
very ordinary people we're not known at
all in their own type of Malcolm X
obviously was different and also why
they seemed important to us today
where'd you grow up here in Washington
where'd you go to school I went to the
Landon school which is in Bethesda
private boys school and then I went to
Princeton took I did my undergraduate
degree at Princeton and I did my
graduate work at Harvard you remember
when you first got interested in history
well I think it's hard to grow up in
Washington or not be interested in
history I mean I I think my interest in
history grew up sort of alongside my
interest in politics and both of them I
think were a result of growing up in
Washington and growing up in a family
that was very interested in public
events uh and I had good teachers in
high school and in college who who made
history seem exciting to me and
important to me actually one of the the
things that that most interested me in
history was taking a course at Princeton
most interested me in history as a
possible career I was taking a course in
Princeton
with the new head of the National
Endowment for the Humanities Sheldon
Hackney who was then a professor in the
history department at Princeton and who
taught courses in southern history and
reading southern history and southern
literature even though I'm not myself a
historian of the South primarily uh
really made me he gave me a sense of how
powerful history can be and how
important historical writing can be
would your parents do for a living
my father's a journalist my mother was a
journalist before she got married father
David Brinkley right I asked that of
Doug Brinkley who was here doing a
history book and he said no it's the
other guy we're not related
what impacted living around your
father's profession have on you
well I think it gave me an interest in
writing and there were it was a house
full of books and it certainly gave me
an interest in politics and political
people and I I grew up around other
journalists and political figures it
didn't make me a journalist obviously
but it perhaps moved me into a field of
history that is as its critics often
point out as perhaps closer to
journalism than other fields I'm not a
medievalist for example both my brothers
are journalists so I I think growing up
in in me and my family obviously had a
had an effect on the way I think and
what interested me we have a lot of
journalists in that seat in a lot of
academics and there's always a dispute
between history when academics write it
and when journalists write can you
explain the kind of techniques that you
have to use in a book versus what a
journalist does on history well I don't
think it's a rigid distinction and there
are journalists who write very good
history and they're historians who write
journalism from time to time and
including me I think the difference
between journalism and history and I
want to make a distinction between
journalism and history and journalists
and historians because that's the
distinction as much fuzzier is is a
level of analysis
that in journalism the effort is to
explain events in the context of today
and many journalists even writing
history attempt to use history as a way
of illuminating some very particular
contemporary issue there's also a
tendency in journalism to emphasize
story and that's I think one of the
reasons why it's so much popular history
the history that ordinary Americans and
generally the general readership are
reads is written not by scholars but by
journalists because they have a real
sense of narrative and story that in
among academic historians has been I
think it's many ways sadly in decline
for some years on the other hand
academic history it seems to me strives
at least to reach a little deeper into
stories then then journalism does and to
link up the particular historical
stories that we're telling with larger
theoretical and analytical analytical
arguments that are going on within the
profession and sometimes also within the
society as well I'm sounding very vague
here and it's because there isn't any
very easy way to explain the distinction
it's not in any way a rigid distinction
and as I say some of the very best
history particularly of relatively
recent events is written by by people
coming out of journalism rather than out
of the Academy in the back of your book
and first of all let me see if we can
get a good close-up here Craig real
close on this where did this come from
the cover that's a painting that I use
in the National Gallery of Art of New
York City in in the late 19th century by
Sloan American artist so your idea no it
was found by the designer I think it's a
very very handsome painting the book was
written it's a canopic written for what
audience well it was written for two
audiences it's the the trade edition
which you're holding in your hand is
published by Knopf and that's obviously
aimed at a general readership it's sold
in bookstores and uh it's the idea is to
tap into an audience of readers who were
interested in the general history of the
United States and don't find very many
of them now
there's also another addition to the
exact same book but another published by
mcgraw-hill which is meant for the
college textbook market how does that
work by the way I mean McGraw who owns
Canal a Knopf and mcgraw-hill are
completely separate on the same book
yeah and it was a deal between the two
publishers mcgraw-hill is the principal
publisher of this book and and kunafa
made an agreement with I I published
mine on my oven other sort of non
textbook books with CONOPS of that
perhaps was one reason why Knopf was was
eager to do this but there was an
agreement between the the college
division of mcgraw-hill and the trade
division of Connaught that mcgraw-hill
would publish a college edition and
Knopf would publish a trade edition is
it hard to sell a book for 40 bucks well
I haven't seen the sales figures but I
suspect it is but it's it's a big book
and absolutely what heavily policed oh
well it's hard to say because the there
the pricing system for textbook
marketing is very arcane and I don't
really even know what it varies from
place to place depending on how many
copies are being sold and in the back
you have a matter of fact some
statistics that could probably solve a
lot of arguments that we have right here
at this immediate area when we do call
and chose and that about numbers of
people that vote and the number of
people's the you know the breakdown of
the population and the different kinds
of people live in this country you have
and this let me ask you why you put
these in first of all you put the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution in the back of the book any
other reason in the obvious for
publishing well I I assume it's obvious
I think those are documents too
readers of American history at students
of American history need and/or want
constantly to refer the Constitution in
particular Manoa any general history of
the United States that doesn't include
those at some point then you have the
presidential elections and the thing I I
found interesting was the the list of
those that ran for the presidents the
different years but the percentage of
the voter turnout yeah
and as a matter of fact you go back I
think that the first one you've got
listed here is John Quincy Adams where
it shows that only twenty six point nine
percent voter participation
that's far and away the lowest well it
is and the reason for that is that in
the early nineteenth century there were
so many restrictions on on voting that
great numbers of people I mean there are
obvious categories of people who could
not vote and in fact you weren't even
counted women are not even counted in
those figures because women couldn't
vote until but couldn't vote universally
until until 1920 but there were also
property requirements and other
restrictions on the franchise and one of
the reasons for putting those figures in
there is to show the dramatic changes in
the levels of turnout from the 1820s
onward as some of these property
requirements requirements were removed
and white men at least were permitted to
vote largely without restriction and I
know in the 20th century of course the
issue of voter turnout is one that that
still concerns us and I think it's
interesting and important to know how
the voter turnout has fluctuated since
since the end of the 19th century the
voter turnout in 1864 the Abraham
Lincoln year was eighty one point two
earlier than that the William Henry
Harrison was 80 point two and then you
come forward you know in the 1900s you
had as high as 65 percent with the
William Howard Taft and I think that's
about the highest on that paid zaror you
dipped down over the Warren Harding was
only 49 percent turnout Coolidge was 48
percent turnout and then you you come
into a period where it's in the 60s all
through what was that
my hosting the story that there first of
all there was a big change in the level
of voter participation around that
starting around the turn of the century
and the reasons for that are debated
among historians and probably more
complicated than I should try to explain
here but they they involve the declining
importance of parties in in American
life in the early 20th century one of
the things that made the early 20th
century such an age of reform as it's
often called was a sense that the
parties the political parties had
acquired too much power in American life
and so there were assaults on parties
from all sides in many different forms
many of the features of political life
today that we sometimes find useful or
troubling the the referenda questions on
state ballots the nonpartisan elections
in some cities for mayor even such
little things as moving some local
elections to off years mayoral elections
in New York for example right now we're
beginning a mayoral campaign which was
deliberately moved to a year that was
not a presidential year to limit the
power of parties because the assumption
was that parties wouldn't be able to
turn out the vote as effectively for
simply for a local election as they
could for a national election so a whole
range of reforms and and also a
different political style emerged in the
20th century which made parties less
important and once parties lesson became
less important voting became less
important people didn't vote in such
large numbers in the late 19th century
because they were more politically aware
and knowledgeable than they are now it
was because they had a sort of emotional
bond with their political parties it was
comparable to the bonds that people
often have with their families or their
churches or their communities and that
bond was weakened in the early 20th
century and that that resulted in this
slide in the the total number of people
voting that began early in the century
and continues continued in fluctuating
ways since then now the other point you
you you note is the declining voter
turnout in the 1920s and then it's
rebounded
in the 30s and for a while beyond that
and that although I'm not sure that this
is the only explanation but I think the
primary explanation is that in 1920
women got the vote for the first time
and so they're included in these figures
and for the first few elections women
were not accustomed to voting not yet
registered to vote in large numbers and
so many potential voters female voters
just didn't vote for the first Fuel the
national elections and then by the time
women of women became absorbed into the
electorate at about the same level as
men you find the voter turnout returning
to more or less the same level that had
been in the period just before woman
suffrage you could make the same case
actually about the voter turnout
declining voter turnout since the early
1970s
that's when what eighteen year olds
began to vote and voter turnout rates
dropped precipitously as soon as
eighteen year olds were enfranchised
and they've remained low because
eighteen year olds still don't vote in
high numbers the other thing on the list
that you notice it sticks right out
first of all the only person in history
to get more than 50 million votes and
maybe correct me if I'm wrong is Ronald
Reagan and that right beside it is you
know electoral vote he got 525 only 13
for the other side he just seems to
stick out there as a tremendous vote
getter
well obvious how do you read that
obviously he was now the the the
absolute number of votes that he was the
only person to get 50 million votes says
more about the fact that the population
was growing and he caught a much smaller
percentage of the vote or at least a
significantly smaller percentage of the
vote than Richard Nixon did in 1972 and
that Franklin Roosevelt did in 1936
Lyndon Johnson in 1964 but given our
contemporary political malaise as I
think it might rightly be called and the
the difficulties that almost every
president since Lyndon Johnson has had
in getting in sustaining popularity
Ronald Reagan does stand out it's a
striking anomaly no he had his problems
of course in his second term
but he's really the first president
since Dwight Eisenhower I think who
managed to leave office with a
reasonable level of popularity and of
course he was the first president since
Eisenhower we sort of two full terms you
know we always see from time to time the
listing by academics of the best
presidents in history how do they do
that there's a poll that some historians
launched I forget when I think in the
early 60s that's sent around to members
of the I think it's through the
organization of American Historians
which is the largest professional
organizations for historians who write
about the United States as opposed to no
Americans who write about France and
Germany and other places and these polls
have been published in in the Journal of
American history and elsewhere from time
to time over the last thirty years or so
and I've always been somewhat skeptical
of them I'm not sure that historians are
any better position to judge who was a
good or a bad president than anyone else
I mean their judgments are just as
political as as any other person's
judgment would be but they're
interesting nevertheless in what's
particularly interesting is to see how
the reputations of presidents rise and
fall in in polls would you list in order
I mean that not all but obviously all
four dimm about they're all 41
individuals but who are your top five we
were my top five well I've never been
asked to actually to do this it's been a
while since the any of these polls have
been conducted and I I don't think I
don't remember ever having been polled
on this subject I think like most
historians unlike all the polls that
have been conducted the top four or five
and I'm not necessarily in this order
for me as for as I say for most scholars
would probably be Lincoln Washington
Jefferson Franklin Roosevelt
beyond that it gets it gets harder and
it's a question of balancing different
elements of presidencies against one
another Woodrow Wilson I think was a
very great president in many ways in a
terrible failure in other ways Harry
Truman I admire in many ways and and but
also strongly disagree with with many
things he did about four or five worst
in history in your opinion well I would
have to say and I'll leave out very
recent presidents because I don't think
I would I would be judging them by
anything more than my own political
standards but I think probably you'd
have to say that the worst few
presidents were the ones immediately
preceding the Civil War James Buchanan
Franklin Pierce now granted it was a
terrible time to be president and and
crises that that were extraordinarily
difficult to solve but the they were
canon in particular were strikingly
ineffective presidents in the face of
extraordinary problems and I think
they've probably been worse than less
competent men who have been president
than James Buchanan for example Warren
Harding probably was the least capable
man to be president but he didn't do as
much damage he didn't face the same
challenges the same level of challenges
and and that I think has to be part of
your evaluation just as it does when
you're trying to find great presidents
Theodore Roosevelt always complained
that he would not be remembered as a
great president because he didn't live
in times that cried out for greatness
now some might disagree and some some do
argue that he was a great president but
certainly Franklin Roosevelt seems to
have a greater claim to greatness not
necessarily because he was a better man
than Theodore Roosevelt or a smarter man
or a more capable man but because he
lived in times that rewarded leadership
to a greater degree than than his cousin
Theodore did another thing that you do
throughout the book and I want to get
back to some of those numbers because
they're interesting things to ask you
about
is you have periodically sections called
two pages called debating the past and
I'll hold this up here this particular
one is about the Civil War what's the
point of this the point is to help
readers to understand that while in
reading this book they're reading a
narrative and they're reading a fairly
straightforward story told by me and
presenting history as if it is a fixed
set of events and facts and
interpretations that in fact the ideas
that they're reading this book are
challenged by historians now I try to
give some sense of even in the text
itself that not everything is cut and
dried in history and that their
disagreements about many issues most
issues but I don't think anything can do
that as effectively is simply showing
what the ways in which historians
disagree with one another and have
always disagreed in the way in which
historical interpretations tend to
reflect the time in which they were are
written the backgrounds of the people
who were writing them and that's what
these little essay is debating the
pastor are trying to demonstrate on the
one on civil the Civil War you say there
are revisionist today that disagree with
the original theory that it was an
accidental unnecessary the work of
interested or fanatical agitators that
was one theory and the other responsible
conflict between opposing and enduring
forces
well the revisionists and just in the
lingo of the profession have tended to
be the people who see the Civil War as a
great and avoidable accident a series of
the product of what one historian called
a blundering generation and the more
traditional view has been that this is
that it was an irreconcilable conflict
born of your reconcilable difference
between the North and the South
particularly in the issue of slavery
this is not an issue frankly that
historians debate very much right now
the causes of the Civil War historical
controversy sort of rise and fall and
the the issue of the causes of the Civil
War just doesn't seem to interest
historians very much anymore but it
probably does interest the American
people a lot more than it interests us
and I thought it would be interesting
to readers to see the way in which
historians over time have disagreed on
this issue and still to some degree
disagree about it when they when they
choose to argue about it what techniques
do you use to keep students interested
or do you care about whether they're
interested of course I care about
whether they're just if they're not
interested they're not learning and do
you mean am i teaching or in in writing
this book no and and when you teach me
how big your how big your classes at
Columbia now
uh well Columbia is a much smaller
College than than Harvard in my classes
they're a much smaller I've had you know
150 200 people oh yeah you know I've
only been at Columbia two years so I
don't have any fast pile of data to draw
from but the course I taught most
recently which was last spring had about
200 students and what techniques do you
use I mean how do you how many times do
you meet them how long are your classes
well these large courses are lecture
courses and they meet twice a week for
at Columbia for an hour and a quarter
most places it's 50 minutes so that's an
additional challenges trying to keep
people in their seats for over an hour
one thing I try to do given this longer
period of the class period that I have
now is to spend some of the time each in
each class responding to questions and
trying to provoke discussion it's not
easy to do that in a large group but
yeah I think it it creates a somewhat
more relaxed atmosphere and it also
breaks down the the sense that students
often have an electric course that
there's this sort of barrier between
them and the instructor the instructor
is a kind of performer standing up at
the front of the room and is completely
unapproachable how long were you at
Harvard I was at Harvard well you know
various capacities I guess I was at
Harvard for about 13 14 years first as a
graduate student and Mensa member of the
faculty have you taught anywhere besides
Harvard and Columbia I taught at MIT for
a few years right after I got out of
graduate school and before going to
going back to Harvard and then I taught
at the City University of New York
Graduate School for several years just
before I came to Columbia do you notice
a change in the student over these last
15 years
well I do it's hard to know how much of
it is a change that reflects the
different universities I've been
teaching in and how much of his a change
that reflects the different times in
which I've taught but yes I do when I
first started teaching was a graduate
student in mid 70s and began teaching
there was still I think among college
students at least at Harvard
a very visible residue of the the 60s
left and a kind of skepticism and a
questioning students were certainly much
less radicalized than they had been
while I was in college in the late 60s
but the questions that they asked I
tended to have been shaped by the
controversies of the 60s the Vietnam War
which of course continued until in one
form or another until 1975 by the early
80s that element in in the undergraduate
student body seemed to me to be
shrinking and and students asked
different kinds of questions and it's
not that they were less skeptical but
they were skeptical about different
things and it would be simplistic too
simplistic I think to say that students
became more conservative in the 1980s
although I think that happened but they
became less interested in ideology I
think and less attracted to ideologies
than then students in the 70s had been
and I don't know whether that's changing
again now or not it's it's you know our
political climate seems to be changing
although in what direction it's hard to
say and students will change along with
it but I'm not sure at this point how to
characterize any change in the 90s have
you ever been involved in government or
politics
no any interest in doing that uh well it
certainly interested in government in
politics I I don't have any particular
interest in holding government office or
has anyone asked me to do so but I my
field is primarily political history and
so obviously I'm very interested in not
just in history of politics and
government but in what's going into
politics and government today do you
have a family
I do I have a wife and a two-year-old
daughter one of the things I didn't see
in this book is a dedication is the book
like this I mean most of your books have
dedications to them yeah I think because
this book was aimed at imparted a sort
of college textbook market for witch
dedications are not normally included I
I didn't think to include one I wish in
a way I have put one in but I didn't
think of it too
you point out in the beginning that this
is a you you did a much longer series of
writings about history with some of your
colleagues
Richard current Frank Fidel and Harry
Williams write this book emerged out of
a much longer book that that I have been
the principal author of for about 1213
years now which is a more conventional
college textbook called American history
a survey rather prosaic title for which
I'm not responsible which I inherited in
effect from the three kiss torian's you
mentioned Frank Fidel who was my advisor
at Harvard and who passed away earlier
this year thierry williams who's a
famous civil war historian also
biographer of Huey Long at LSU who died
in the 70s and Richard current who's a
Lincoln scholar and among other things
who was still very much alive and and
still writing and publishing but I took
the book over from them in in but I
guess 1980 and I've been the only author
of that book since then the only active
author and that's not a book that I
think a general readership would would
tend to read because it's first of all
much longer than this it's almost twice
as long as this book and it has much
more of the apparatus of a text book
threaded through it this book came about
for two reasons it came about out of a
sense among the college textbook
publishing people with whom I work that
there was a growing market among
students and faculty for shorter and
more readable histories that the the
big textbooks that are so much a feature
of academic life are now coming to be
too big for many students partly because
a lot of professors like to assign
collateral reading and they don't have
time for people to read so much of the
textbook and then for other reasons as
well then the other motive behind this
book was the sense that there might be a
market among a general readership to for
a relatively succinct I'm this is not a
short book by any means but compared to
college textbooks it's a relatively
succinct history of all of all of
American history
historians academic scholars don't write
these kind of syntheses anymore for any
purpose other than textbooks textbook
sirs really are really the only kind of
synthetic writing broad synthetic
writing that historians do anymore and
since most textbooks have multiple
authors and most textbooks are market
driven rather than driven by the
interests and and interpretations of the
authors they tend to have a kind of
fragmented quality that doesn't make
them particularly interesting to general
readers I wanted in this book to do some
to take the the kernel of a textbook
that this act of synthesis that
historians engage in and turned it into
something that would be more readable
and more accessible both to students and
to general readers and how will I
succeed to know that the readers will
have to decide that that was the that
was the idea
and so I stripped out a lot of what a
lot of the detail that that instructors
expect in big textbooks and I tried to
make the narrative flow more smoothly
and I tried to make it a little more
interpretive than textbooks generally
are in the back you list under every
chapter in a bibliography all the books
that were you know suggested that you
can go get more detail on unfortunetely
but have you read all those before snot
their army their thousands of hundreds
at least and perhaps thousands of books
back there no that's really a those are
not footnotes those are not
references sources I have used I've read
many of them but not anywhere close to
all of them probably not even majority
of them but it's an effort to give
students an idea of what books are
available to them if they want to learn
more about the areas in which they're
reading in such concise form in this
book in the back as we talked again I
mean we talked earlier there are charts
and another chart that you have back
here is lost my place is a population of
the United States and because the way
it's configured it's hard for the
artists to see it on the screen but I
just the thing you can easily report
here is that of course every year the
population every 10 years has gone up
percentage of increase this last time
around 1990 was one of the smallest in
history I mean over the years it was up
in the 30s in the early years and it was
only nine point nine percent increase in
1990 next to that is the population per
square mile that's gone from four point
five in the early days up to seventy
point three population per square mile
percent of urban versus rural that keeps
going up in the early days it was five
point one it goes all the way up the
highest that's ever been to 77 point
five percent of urban to rural
percentage of white and non-white that
start out at 80 point seven percent
white in the United States back in 1790
and it went all the way up to where at
one point back in the 50s it was 89
percent back now down to 80 point three
where it was in the beginning
one more here and I'll let you get your
response to all this the median age the
earliest year recorded was back in 1820
it was sixteen point seven was the
median age and it's gone all the way up
now to the highest point in history to
thirty-two point nine what is all that
tell you about what's happening in the
country well tells tells us many things
I think and maybe the best way to answer
is just to explain why the figures like
that seemed to me to be useful in a book
like this I I think when we we tend to
focus in our discussion of public events
contemporary public events and to some
degree also in our discussion of
historical events on people
vents on things that are easily visible
and it's easy to forget that underline
what is happening to us today and what's
happened to America throughout history
is a series of profoundly important
demographic changes changes in the size
of the population the structure of the
population the geographical and spatial
distribution of the population and while
it's very hard to draw direct
connections between those changes and
the specific events that we tend to
focus on when we're writing history it
seems to me and to many other historians
very clear that these large structural
demographic changes have at least as
much to do and probably much more to do
with the way our history evolves than
what presidents have done at any
particular time or what any particular
leader or group has done or institution
has done and obviously putting numbers
like that in the chart in the back in a
chart in the back of a book it doesn't
do very much to explain their
significance but I've tried in in the
text of the book as well to make
reference to to these demographic
changes and I wanted to make it possible
for readers to get a sense of how
dramatic some of these changes were the
next page is I think there may be an
opportunity for you to comment on why
it's employment from the year 1870 to
1990 and in 1870 there were 12.5 million
people employed in the United States and
it's gone up steadily to 124 point eight
million people next to it though it's
male female employment ratio back in
1870 it was 85 percent male 15 percent
female all the way now to words that
closest it's ever been it's 54 percent
male 46 percent female and then the next
column and I'll hold it up so the
audience can see is the number of people
in unions percentage of people that are
in the United States and unions keeps
going down and you can see the 1990 it's
gone down to as low as 16 percent of the
workers that are part of unions there in
that column what do you read into those
numbers well I think the the division
between male and female employment
speaks for itself and that's been one of
the most daunting social changes in our
recent history and I suspect that number
will continue to narrow I don't
that'll ever reach parody although it
might but I it it speaks I think to the
enormous impact that feminism and other
social forces that have driven women of
the workplace have had in the last 50
years or so the percentage of people in
unions I guess that also more or less
speaks for itself I mean you say it's
continued to go down that's true in the
last 30 years or so but there's also a
period in the 20th century when it went
steadily up and reached a peak shortly
after World War Two it was the highest
percentage there was in 1941 27% of the
population were members of unions and I
think that that speaks both about the
institutional problems of early
institutional successes that unions have
had and the institutional problems
they've had since then maybe more to the
point it speaks to the relative
importance of the industrial sector of
our economy in recent years and one of
the reasons the unions have declined so
dramatically in recent years is that
industrial jobs where unions are most
likely to be effective have declined as
well early in the book you quote I don't
know that you find it gladstone the
famous famous Brit to saying it's either
about our Constitution or about this
country whose being the greatest ever
created can you remember the
Constitution I think is what Gladstone
was referring to and I actually don't
remember the precise quote that you're
referring to but there is an important
theme in American history and we see
this certainly today and debates about
what the Supreme Court should be doing
and what the Constitution means the
United States one of the things that
made the United States so different from
England politically after the American
Revolution was that we chose to write
down our Constitution the English
Constitution which is much venerated in
England is an unwritten document it's
simply an understanding of the way
things work I and the first generation
of citizens of the United States that
people who wrote our constitute the
revolutionaries and
and their successors who wrote the
Constitution believed that one of the
things that had created the difficulties
between the United States and England
that had corrupted English society in a
way that made the revolution necessary
was precisely the fact that the
Constitution was unwritten and therefore
could be corrupted and perverted by
phenol and self-interested leaders as
they believed the king and some of his
ministers had been so creating a written
constitution for the United States was
one of the crucial things that separated
the United States from England having
done that Americans tended to give to
this document a kind of veneration that
in many ways survives to this day
although perhaps not as strongly as it
once did
and the Constitution was described as
sacred the the framers of the
Constitution were remembered as the
founding fathers although that's a
phrase that really didn't come into
currency until the 1920s but were
treated almost as demigods by later
generations during much of the 19th
century when the federal government was
very weak in American society was very
provincial and fragmented the the
veneration of the Constitution was one
of the few things that gave Americans a
sense of themselves as being part of a
single nation I in the 20th century that
veneration has survived in many ways but
it has also started to be challenged and
we now see on the one hand people
insisting on using the Constitution as a
as a bulwark against social changes
social and cultural changes insisting on
interpreting it through the idea of
original intent and others who who argue
the Constitution is a very flexible
document that was meant to respond to
changes in the times and then there are
others now who say the Constitution
itself is archaic that is saddled us
with a government that may have worked
very well in the nineteenth century
but is not working well in the 20th
century I found the quote William
Gladstone says page 147 the Constitution
the US Constitution the most wonderful
work ever struck off at a given time by
the brain and purpose of man well that
was a view widely shared by Americans
and perhaps still is and it's hard to
argue with the idea that I'm not sure
I'd use quite the superlatives the
Gladstone uses but it's hard to argue
that the the American Constitution has
been a extraordinarily successful
experiment I mean the government that
was created at a particular moment by a
group of men that has survived now for
two hundred and almost two hundred well
a little over two hundred years and for
all the problems that our government has
today it's still a remarkably stable
political system and one has to be
impressed now there were flaws in the
Constitution some of which we have
corrected over time through amendments
and some of which remain uncorrect 'add
but it's hard to think of another moment
of State Building of Constitution
building in in the history of human
civilization that has created so
successful a political system and so
enduring the one you said earlier that
your father's a journalist and your two
brothers are journalists word do they
work my brother Joel is works for the
New York Times he's an editor in the
Washington bureau it was prior to that
was the Times correspondent in Israel
and my brother John is the Washington
correspondent for the Rocky Mountain
News which is a Scripps Howard paper now
when you all get together you're the
only historian in the family do you find
that you look at the world differently
huh not particularly
III think many people like to believe
that
when one becomes a Nestorian one has a
perspective on the world that is
different and therefore of a particular
value to everyone else and I think no
effort to disabuse them of that but I
think to some degree it's a myth I don't
think that my view of contemporary
events is any more knowledgeable or
perceptive than
that of my brothers maybe less so it I
think I know more about history than
they do but they probably know more
about today than I do you said earlier
that one of the things you find when you
teach students about the 20 century is
that a lot that they they don't know
what are the things that you can
remember that most surprised your
students about the early 20th century or
even later in the 40s and 50s well it's
hard to say I don't I mean I don't have
a pipeline into into my students mind
and and what dozen does not surprise
them I think that I think back to my own
experience as a college student studying
history and I think what surprises
people most often are things they learn
that are that contradict sort of popular
conventional wisdom I mean history is
referred to constantly in in our public
conversations not not always very
reflectively but it's you know we we
always refer to the the today we were
for constantly to the legacy of Vietnam
to the legacy of the 60s to eunuch
analogy and I think what surprises
students is how much more complicated
and contestant these legacies are then
the the glib way in which they're used
in contemporary politics would it would
have led them to believe I think what
also surprises students is that people
who are remembered popularly in black
and white as the heroes of recent
history or the the goats and villains of
recent history are also more complicated
and interesting usually than then they
then they would tend to believe people
are very surprised when I talk about
Franklin Roosevelt
and surprised to find out first of all
how much of the New Deal didn't work how
much of it was abandoned even before was
have died how complicated Franklin
Roosevelt was and how complicated his
ideology was that's just one example
people are surprised when I talk about
Richard Nixon who's not the figure whom
I admire but nevertheless I I think
there are many extraordinarily
impressive things about the Nixon's
career and about his presidency and
people are very surprised to discover
for example that it was Richard Nixon
not a Democrat who proposed the only
really profound reform of the welfare
system since 1935 the Family Assistance
Plan which was never passed but it was a
presumably a conservative Republicans
the only president ever to have proposed
a guaranteed income as the basis of our
welfare system when he lectured you
speak extemporaneously or you speak from
notes you have audio-visual aids or I
don't have audio-visual aids
I do have notes and I speak from the
notes sometimes when I speak
extemporaneously and at other times but
I do like to work out pretty carefully
what I'm going to say before I stand up
to say it when you test a student what's
what system do you use well I tend to
use to ask people write essays and I
tend to to give them fairly broad sort
of interpretive statements to respond to
and ask them to find examples and
illustrations to support their arguments
so I don't ask specific questions very
often I don't think history is a process
of memorizing names and dates and should
not be although of course it's important
to know some names and dates I think
understanding history means learning how
to think about history and had a
Marshall the the so-called facts that
you know behind an argument and
interpretation that's what I try to
encourage students to do you have a
favorite or favorite historians that you
look to people that you either have
modeled your own writing after or if you
you would go pick up off the shelf and
read yours if you had time oh well there
are many historians whom I admire and
whom I always read when their books come
out or some of them of course sir
they're no longer living or no longer
writing I I mean I I hate to to make a
list because I at the risk of offending
the people I leave off it one historian
whom I I've always deeply admired is
Richard Hofstadter who whom I never knew
died in the early 70s but who who taught
at Columbia is as I now do and even
though his books now seemed in many ways
very dated and present interpretations
that most historians including me
largely disagree with now he III found
to be an extraordinarily event Evander
Fist Orion in the story and who was
willing to take chances
using interdisciplinary methods and
story who wrote beautifully who tried to
make his writing important not just as
scholars but also to to other readers I
can't say it modeled my career on
Richard Hofstadter and
you know I should be so lucky as to be
as a greater the story in this as he was
but he certainly has had an influence on
the way I thought I'm a great admirer of
C Vann Woodward those of course still
very much alive still writing as a
friend of mine and who's reading his
work in college his work on southern
history had a had a big impact on me and
the way I thought about history and I
think I'll stop there I mean there are
many others who I admire but I what's
next
well I'm finishing I hope in the next
month or so a book that I've been
working on that I worked on alongside
this one for four more years that I'd
like to admit about the way in which
liberals new dealers in the late 30s and
the 1940s redefined what they thought
the government should do and it is a
book about how what came after the war
to be known as New Deal liberalism took
the form it did which is in many ways
very different from the form it had in
the brilliant mid 30s when the New Deal
itself was most active so that's that's
what I'm working on at the moment
and then I'm also just starting a
biography of Henry Luce the founder and
publisher of time and life and fortune
why Henry lives well I think I mean
there are lots of reasons why I'm doing
it but what I think makes him
interesting to me is that he it's an
opportunity to look in a very precise
way at some of the intersections between
politics and culture
I think the magazines that Luce created
and that he guided so directly through
through most of his life had an enormous
impact on American culture and also were
anonymously reflective of at least some
strains of American culture Luce was
also very active in and at times
influential in politics and and the
combination of those two things made him
interesting to me I think politics and
culture have tended to be treated as
very separate areas and again anyone
watching our politics today has to be
aware that they're not separate at all
they're inextricable and so I hope in
this book to to be able to explore that
that connection our guest has been the
author of this book called the
unfinished nation a concise history of
the American people professor Alan
Brinkley is at Columbia University and
we thank you very much for joining us my
pleasure thank you